>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hong Ta-Moore: My
name is Hong Ta-Moore.
Reference librarian for
Southeast Asian collection
in the Asian division.
Thank you for joining
us today for a lecture
on shadow theater in Indonesia.
In collaboration with
the embassy of Indonesia,
the Asian division is honored to
have two distinguished experts
in the field of Balinese
shadow theater to talk to us
about this ancient form of
storytelling through the use
of puppets and shadows.
Due to time constraints,
please hold your
questions until the end.
With us today we have Dr. Andy
McGraw, an associate professor
of music at the University
of Richmond, Virginia.
He received his Ph.D.
in ethnomusicology
at Wesleyan University in 2005
and has published extensively
on traditional and experimental
music in southeast Asia.
His performances and
collaborations have appeared
on the [inaudible]
importer labels.
He is the author of
"Radical Traditions.
Reimagining Culture in
Bali's Contemporary Music"
which was published in 2013
by Oxford University Press,
and co-editor of "Performing
Indonesia" published in 2016
by the Smithsonian Publications.
His current monograph
project entitled "Good Music,
Sound Ethics is an Ethnography
of Music as Ethical Practice
in Four Alternative
Communities."
A monastery, jail,
commune, and village.
Also joining us is
Mr. Gusti Sudarta,
a Balinese shadow master,
musician, composer,
dancer, and choreographer.
At age six, Mr. Sudarta began
extensive and continuous study
of traditional Balinese
performing arts, music, dance,
and theater with family
members and master performers
in the villages of [inaudible].
He has been a permanent
faculty member at the Institute
of the Arts in [inaudible]
since 1991.
He is a renown performer of
Balinese traditional forms
and is at the forefront of
contemporary experimentation.
He has performed extensively
in Asia, Europe, Australia,
and America conducting
three world tours
with [inaudible] project
between 1998 and 2003.
He is currently pursuing
his Ph.D.
at SIS [inaudible] Indonesia.
Please join me to
welcome our guests.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Andy McGraw: Hi, folks.
Thanks for coming.
So this is how this
talk is going to go.
We're going to demonstrate
some traditional shadow theater
techniques and talk about
a traditional performance
that has informed
some experimental work
that Pat Gutsi has been doing.
And what we'll do first is I'll
give a really brief introduction
on Indonesia and Bali
and shadow theater,
and then I'll hand
it over to Pat Gusti.
He's not completely
fluent in English
so the way we put this paper
together was yesterday I sat
down with him and
interviewed him on this topic,
wrote up the notes in English,
and he will be reading
them today,
and I'll be running the slides
and showing the video and kind
of coming back and maybe
helping pronunciation if
and when it needs a little
bit of clarification.
So I'm assuming if
you're in the room,
you know where the
nation of Indonesia is.
I don't need to go very
deeply into this, I hope,
other than to remind you
that it's very large,
very complicated nation with a
lot of different ethnicities.
A lot of different languages and
many, many waves of migrations.
So a lot of religious
syncretism, cultural syncretism,
and in Bali and Java, a really
complicated mix of Buddhists,
Hindu, and Islamic
ideas, cultural practices,
and mixture with
indigenous animism.
That's all I'm going
to go with that.
We could spend the rest of the
talk on it but I get a sense
that you already know this.
Here is a sense of
Bali and its regencies.
Pat Gutsi is from the village
of [inaudible] and [inaudible]
which was the seat of
the Balinese kingdom
when the military
expedition from [inaudible]
in the 14th century came over
to Bali and changed a lot
of Balinese culture and
introduced new religious
and cultural practices.
So, Pat Gutsi and I have
been working together
since about 2001, 2002.
So he is one of my teachers of
the rather specialized music
that accompanies the
Balinese shadow play.
It's called [inaudible],
but we've done a lot
of collaborations
together over the years.
And we were just
performing this weekend
at the IluminAsia Festival
over at the Smithsonian Saturday
night and then Sunday morning
and then over at the Kennedy
Center Sunday evening.
And we'll show you
some footage from that.
I assume also that you know WMR.
So could we show the traditional
shadow puppets of Indonesia.
It's buffalo hide
that's been perforated,
cut, and then painted.
Why do they paint it when
you only see the shadow?
It's both to help remind the
puppeteer or the [inaudible]
of the character
traits of the puppets,
but also because the audience
often sits on both sides
of the screen and they move
around the performances.
And after our talk, you
can get a chance to come up
and check them out more closely.
So what we thought what we would
do is actually open up this talk
by Pat Gutsi doing the
traditional [inaudible].
The [inaudible] is
the tree of life.
Sometimes called the [inaudible]
in the [inaudible] tradition,
and it dances to create
the universe of the play.
So we found what we would open
up with a traditional
[inaudible] performance
and then what's called
the [inaudible]
or the fragrant forest
which is the scene
in which the [inaudible]
recites poetry
in the [inaudible]
language that sets the scene
and introduces the main
characters before Pat Gutsi
reads his section of the paper.
So what we'll do here is we'll
play -- so we have some music.
We'll play; if this
works, we'll play the scene
from the Kennedy Center
performance yesterday.
So we had some music to
accompany the [inaudible] here.
Oh, error loading media file.
Wonderful.
Nice. Yes.
Let's see.
Let's try it one more time.
There we go.
Cue it up.
>> If you click on
select [inaudible].
>> Yes. I want you to look
at him though and listen.
[ Music ]
So when you hear that knocking
it's him hitting the side
of the shadow puppet box and
that wakes the puppets up
and invites the gods
to descend into them.
[ Inaudible comment ]
>> I will.
I will. Look at him now.
[ Music ]
So there were moments in there
where I think you can
see it represents wind,
represents water,
represents land.
And then what he would do
is he would sing the scene
for [inaudible] and he
chose some special texts
for these performances based
on a legend called Sutasoma.
A story called Sutasoma.
Normally it's a different
text that's used,
but he took this text from
this story, and the author
or the scribe that
set this version
of Sutasoma has been informing
Pat Gutsi's experimental work.
So we wanted to start from there
so you have a sense of the kind
of evolution from
the traditional text
to the experimental work that
we'll show later at the end.
And I'll slide through the
translations of the [inaudible]
that he's going to sing.
That would be the next
session of the shadow play.
[ Singing ]
Sorry.
[ Foreign language ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: I'm going
to talk today about the story
of Sutasoma and the place
and describe [inaudible]
who played the story
through his poetry.
During the [inaudible] in
the central Balinese kingdom
of [inaudible], Sutasoma
is believed
to be the grandson
of [inaudible].
The last king mentioned in
the Hindu Mahabharata epic.
The story combines elements
of Hinduism and Buddhism
and Sutasoma himself is
thought to be the [inaudible].
The supreme Buddha in the
[inaudible] tradition.
Today the story is well-known in
Bali especially in the village
of [inaudible] with its
history of Buddhists priests.
And among the flowers
[inaudible] that combines Hundi,
Buddhists, and Muslim elements.
[Inaudible] in this
story [inaudible]
or Balinese religion.
As this thing from
Indian tradition
because it combines
many different beliefs
and for most religious
pluralism.
The story of Sumasota begins
with Purusada, an honorable king
who enjoys hunting [inaudible].
This is Purusada.
Purusada enjoyed eating the
animals he hunted and one day
of his assistants accidentally
cut his finger while cooking the
animal he cut bleeding
into the food.
[Inaudible] found this meal
the most delicious and it awoke
in him an animal
nature that grew --
>> Andy McGraw: Ferociously.
So the assistant
cut his own fingers.
Not [inaudible].
>> Gusti Puti Sudarta: He
became addicted to the taste
of human flesh and begin
to become a cruel ruler
enforcing corporal punishment
to feed his habit.
Slowly he became
[inaudible], an ogre.
One day, [inaudible] endured
himself in [inaudible]
so he asked for help
from [inaudible] the
god of time and death.
Kali demanded the corpses
of 100 kings in [inaudible]
and so [inaudible] begin to
wage war across the country
in the form of the
[inaudible] ogre, [inaudible].
[Inaudible] like that.
[ Laughter ]
Eventually Kali demanded
Sutasoma,
the king of the [inaudible]
as a sacrifice as well.
[Inaudible] as you know is
very handsome king like that.
[Inaudible].
[ Singing ]
Very handsome and
very fine character.
So Sutasoma's brother-in-law
Dasabahu,
this character Dasabahu.
[Inaudible].
Dasabahu was given a
bone by Lord Brahma
and Purusada was given a
bone by Lord [inaudible],
a manifestation of Shiva.
Because they were
both very powerful,
they were destroy
the environment.
It looked like a
nuclear wasteland.
Eventually Purusada
defeated Dasabahu.
When Sutasoma came out of
the court to face Prusada,
all of the flowers
begin to bloom again.
The aura of the Buddha
brought the land back to life.
When Purusada saw this
he suddenly became aware
of what he had become and
asked, "Why have I done this?
Why have I become [inaudible]?"
Purusada begged Sutasoma
for forgiveness and asked
to become his disciple.
But Sutasoma first
offered himself a sacrifice
to [inaudible] who
became an innermost dragon
in [inaudible] and swallow him.
[Inaudible] already transformed
to be the giant dragon.
[ Growling ]
Just as he swallowed
Sutasoma's feet [inaudible]
that time cannot eat Suma
because it's the Buddha.
It transcends time itself
and so like Purusada
and [inaudible] begged
for forgiveness and asked
to become his disciple.
The story of Sutasoma includes
very important poem called the
[inaudible] structures
[inaudible].
[ Singing ]
>> Andy McGraw: This is a very
creative translation here.
It's said that there
are two truths.
One known as Buddha
and one as Shiva.
[ Singing ]
And they appear different
but in fact spiritual truth
cannot be split in two.
[ Singing ]
Truly the essence of
Buddhism and Shivaism are one.
The deepest truth.
[ Singing ]
It's difference is
only apparent.
In diversity there is oneness.
An essence that cannot
be divided
because it encompasses
everything.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: In Bali
this poem is often sung during
the [inaudible].
It evokes a feeling
of a beautiful blooming
spring transition.
Now this idea of
religious pluralism,
[inaudible] essential
oneness has in my opinion,
a very strong moral
ethics and it relates
to [inaudible] political
and historical context.
[Inaudible] outside the
court during the rule
of [inaudible] whose prime
minister [inaudible] wanted
to expand the [inaudible] empire
through military expedition.
[Inaudible] didn't agree with
this military state approach.
He thought that [inaudible]
could expand through hearts
and minds, through
diplomacy rather than force.
He believed that force
would only lead to problems
and temporary [inaudible].
And this is exactly
what happened
in [inaudible] military
expedition
in Bali in [inaudible].
[Inaudible] thought
that religious tolerancy
and pluralism was an
essential part of diplomacy.
He followed the Buddhist
tradition but was open
to the Shiva teachings.
[Inaudible] himself was Hindu
while [inaudible] was Buddhist
with some Chinese ancestry.
The eventual collapse of
the [inaudible] empire
in the 15th century was partly
due to the religious tension
between the Hindu
rulers [inaudible]
and his Muslim son [inaudible].
Indonesia independence.
[Inaudible] Indonesia
[inaudible] incorporates many
concepts from the Sutasoma story
in developing the
nation's philosophy.
This is clearly seen in
the [inaudible] principles,
[inaudible] first expressed
by [inaudible] in 1945,
[inaudible] believed in one God.
[Inaudible].
A unified Indonesia.
[Inaudible], democracy, and
[inaudible] social justice.
These five principles
are displayed
under the national motto of
[inaudible] united in diversity.
The relationship
between the [inaudible]
and bravery expressed in
Sutasoma is symbolized
in the Indonesian flag.
The white symbolizing
[inaudible] position
symbolize [inaudible].
If you have a [inaudible] you
can avoid the need for violence.
[Inaudible] without
[inaudible] creates confusion.
Religious pluralism.
Adopting the principles
of religious tolerancy
and pluralism from Sutasoma was
a strategic move for [inaudible]
who was attempting to
unite the inhabitants
of [inaudible] Islands
representing hundreds
of ethnicities, language, and
culture in a single new nation.
But a spirit of [inaudible]
tolerancy was already present
in many of these cultures.
My father who lived from 1917
and 2004 was a traditional
healer,
village priest, and
a [inaudible].
In his personal library, he had
many traditional Balinese Hindu
and Buddhist parliament
manuscripts, Christian text,
[inaudible] text, Islamic texts
including the Javanese written
by [inaudible], and
writings by [inaudible].
His attitude wasn't
dogmatic or fanatical.
If he thought a text
or tradition includes valuable
teachings he would adopt them.
He would say [inaudible].
>> Andy McGraw: Which
we didn't translate.
That means it's got
great stuff in it.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: I
do not think he was unusual
for his generation.
I know of many other Balinese
who read a similar combination
of texts from several
religious traditions.
In fact, in Bali there
is a strong tradition
of religious pluralism in
connection between Hindu
and Muslim communities.
For Islam in the
village of [inaudible].
>> Andy McGraw: Yes.
There's a good example
that Pat Gutsi found
and he posted it on Facebook.
So we'll see if we can -- yes.
This was just posted
a couple of days ago.
And you'll see the Muslim
performing the [inaudible]
and the Balinese Hindu
Temple performing.
I don't know.
But here's a short example.
[ Music ]
I really don't like
American Facebook,
but I love Indonesian Facebook.
And I just noticed this.
This is just posted but you've
got people commenting over here.
[Inaudible].
I mean these lines are
right out of Sutasoma.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: Yes.
There is an Islamic
neighborhood that participates
in the temple ceremony
of their Hindu neighbors.
The Muslims often
perform their [inaudible]
in the Hindu temple ceremonies.
And the Hindu's bring a frame
to the Islamic community
on the holy days.
Being careful to avoid pork.
Similar interaction
also occurred in Java
in the of [inaudible].
The Muslims prepared
drinks and refreshments
for the Hindus during
their temple procession.
[Inaudible].
Well, I believe [inaudible] is a
[inaudible] philosophical basis
for the nation.
It's begin to become [inaudible]
and [inaudible] and the
so called [inaudible] and
the [inaudible] and in '98.
During this time, [inaudible]
became [inaudible] school system
and [inaudible] became
required for all [inaudible].
Important [inaudible] against
militarized diplomacy also
seemed to be forgotten.
This was seen [inaudible]
military [inaudible]
which eventually gained
independence from Indonesia
in 1999 after considerable
violence.
Following the [Inaudible]
in 1998,
there has been an increasing
radicalism in politics
and religions, and it is in
this context and [inaudible]
for inspiration for
my creative work.
While Sutasoma was perform
within traditional [inaudible],
it fell out of favor
in the early 1980.
It was considered
too hippy today.
>> Andy McGraw: Heavy.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: Hippy.
[Inaudible] in Bali use
symbol narratives today
with extensive comic
and [inaudible].
I think this [inaudible]
traditional performance provides
the audience with entertainment
in some [inaudible] to take home
with them and think
of [inaudible].
As my father used to say,
a poor man [inaudible].
What is it you can take home you
cannot take home a puppeteer,
fancy techniques
or beautiful voice,
but you can take home
his philosophicalism.
In a way stories like
Sutasoma [inaudible]
in which there is the bit about
the marriage and commonalities
of different [inaudible]
teaching.
We learn how to think
on our own.
To make our own personal
relationship of [inaudible]
but [inaudible] is open
[inaudible] with ethnicity
and [inaudible] political power.
There is also an increasing
fundamentalist tendency towards
[inaudible] pure
[inaudible] teachings either
in Arabic Islam or [inaudible].
[Inaudible] of the unique
Indonesian adaptation
of those tradition.
I worry that there are
[inaudible] political
[inaudible], the unique
philosophical basis
of the nation.
They have gotten the kingdoms
like [inaudible] was manipulated
in setting power and wealth.
The closer of two power you
get, the more [inaudible]
and dogmatic composition
about religion become
as in Jakarta today.
[Inaudible].
This is the situation
that inspired my
experiential theater work,
[inaudible] which I originally
composed for my master thesis
with studying at the Institute
of the Art in [inaudible].
I have seen revised and
perform the works [inaudible].
My idea was to imagine
[inaudible] and the condition
that inspired him to set
the story of Sutasoma.
My regiment includes element
of Balinese and Javanese Hindu,
Buddhist, and Islamic
music and instruments.
I use Balinese [inaudible]
and [inaudible] used
by Muslim communities in Bali.
I also used the [inaudible]
that Indonesian Muslim use
for the call to prayer
in the mosque.
Some of my [inaudible] critique
this approach and accommodate
that I erase the Muslim
aspect of the music
but I think they
missed the point.
Audience enthusiastically
accepted this [inaudible].
The focal of [inaudible] I use
is to create a setting of poetry
from the [inaudible], but
using Muslim instruments
from Indonesia in the
focus style influenced
by Pakistani [inaudible]
Muslim [inaudible] music.
>> Andy McGraw: Give me a
minute while I try to do this.
[ Music ]
So there is the [inaudible]
in the back [inaudible]
tradition [inaudible].
[Inaudible] these guys
are from [inaudible].
These guys are Hindu.
[ Music ]
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: The piece
combines extreme [inaudible]
and mask dancing.
The [inaudible] was performed
using two [inaudible]
for the performance including
a [inaudible] as the source
of the flowering
[inaudible] of world religion.
>> Andy McGraw: So yes,
there was an innovative --
obviously this is innovative.
There's several screens.
There are dancers, but there are
also new puppets that were made.
And so, this puppet
includes an image
of [inaudible], the
ultimate deity.
You'll notice the
symbols around it.
There's many complaints
about the videography.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: Near
the end of the performance,
important [inaudible]
by practicing your
[inaudible], he is vilified.
He is visited by the
character's [inaudible] in Bali,
a court jester who is
actually a wise god.
An incarnation of
Shiva who helps
to guide humans throughout
their dharma.
[Inaudible] important to
compose and arrange the story
of Sutasoma to help deliver
the nation from disaster.
>> Andy McGraw: And this
will be the last example --
I need to find it here.
Then we can open it
up for questions.
It doesn't preview.
Okay. Bear with me for a minute.
[Inaudible].
And that's your niece?
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta: Yes.
>> Andy McGraw: Okay.
Let's see if it's in this one.
Divided up the files strangely
when we loaded it on the PC.
So here is [inaudible] in Bali.
The [inaudible] version is
called [inaudible] who appears
to be a court jester just kind
of a funky guy not very refined
but in fact he's an incarnation
of Shiva to help from below kind
of guide people to
the proper dharma.
And he appears in the show
to help [inaudible] set
and express Sutasoma.
So now there's a kind
of theatrical transition
in which Gutsi appears
now as [inaudible]
but in the mask dance version
who then has the interaction
with Tantula now represented
as a shadow puppet.
And this music we're not
discussing this today,
but this music is quite
[inaudible] as well.
Okay. We'll end it there.
Thank you very much and if you
have questions for Pat Gutsi.
>> I have a question.
So Bali is this tiny
island in a Muslim nation
of that has 1700 islands
and is pretty much the largest
Muslim country in the world
or maybe the second largest.
And since the 1990s we
have these tensions,
these religious tensions
globally, and you only have
to think of [inaudible]
right now.
So I'm wondering Bali has this
unique fusion of Hinduism,
Buddhism, and what's
the other one?
Islam of course.
And Islam is a dominant
religion and sort of Muslim.
Bali is this tiny
island surrounded
by this huge Muslim country.
So to what extent are your
wonderful traditions threated
by the current political events?
To what extent are there
tensions within Indonesia
that threaten the
continuation of your tradition?
No. It's not this
feeling of threat.
Not yet.
>> Andy McGraw: Well,
I'll just add one thing.
I've never really been
able to wrap my head
around the description
of Indonesia
which you often hear
is the world's largest
or most populous Muslim nation.
So much is left out of
that description it's kind
of like saying America has the
most Americans of any country.
There is different kinds of
Islam in Indonesia and a lot
of it, especially in central
Java is very [inaudible],
and obviously it's weird
for me to talk about this
because it's offending
the audience.
So it's a very localized
form of Hinduism.
I've been in mosques in
central Java that have painted
around the interior the
story of the [inaudible].
The [inaudible], the shadow
puppeteers in central Java --
>> Muslim.
>> -- most of them
are Hindu and most
of their audience is Muslim.
So it's a very complicated
scene and a lot of --
even though there are problems
of terminology in Bali,
there are many Balinese
with names like Madai
which is a [inaudible] --
it's a form of birth
order naming in Bali.
They'll have a name like Madai
Mohammed because they're Islamic
and maybe they have some
[inaudible] ancestry
but they've been there for
hundreds and hundreds of years
and they have these
long-standing pretty positive
relationships with their
neighbors of different faiths.
So I think there was a sense of
threat after the bombing in 2002
in Bali because it was a
fundamentalism [inaudible]
in Kuta.
But nothing - I was there at the
time and there wasn't violence
against Muslims that I saw.
Thank you.
>> I [inaudible] because Islam
is the dominant [inaudible] more
Islamic than any other religion.
[Inaudible] that's where they
have those kind of [inaudible]
and they show it in the
building address and everything.
It look more like
[inaudible]Islam [inaudible].
I can [inaudible] I
see all the manuscripts
which are [inaudible]
collections
and [inaudible] language
and they [inaudible] Islamic
[inaudible]but maybe that's what
it is [inaudible].
>> Isn't Hinduism pretty unique
to Indonesia just
focusing on Bali?
>> Andy McGraw: Well, it's
multiple waves, and it was never
through - there doesn't seem to
be a lot of historical evidence
for strong armed prelatizing
before the Dutch arrived
as a colonial power.
But I mean since probably before
the 5th century there's been
Hindu influence, of course,
[inaudible] all these issues
with naming and colonial
naming and religious practices.
But there's also quite an
[inaudible] tradition throughout
that area.
So this summer I was sitting
in a village called [inaudible]
which is [inaudible] village or
sometimes incorrectly described
as pre-Hindu village
[inaudible].
But it's more around would
you call it certain sects.
So that village is
an Indra sect.
So and they identify with
Indra but they have a lot
of what appear to be
Austronesian or even kind
of Polynesian or Hawaiian
type cultural practices there
and [inaudible] in
these kinds of temples.
And I think - it partly had
to do with the Dutch coming
from that direction and
that conditioned a view
of their place like Bali.
Had they come from Hawaii first,
they might have seen a
lot more Austronesian
or Polynesian practice
in a lot of this.
But it's very [inaudible].
It's very mixed and I think
what Pat Gutsi is responding
with a critical eye
against is this eye looking
out for a so-called pure
versions through which
to correct or improve
what has proven over time
to be a quite resilient form
of religious practice in Bali.
Am I putting words in
your mouth [inaudible]?
Elizabeth.
>> Yes. So thank you.
It was wonderful.
So this is really
awe-inspiring in the way
that the [inaudible]
ideals are really elevated
through the interfaith diversity
mixture that this is showing.
And in some ways
it's so impressive
because the traditions
are so strong.
So that in the - in one sense,
the [inaudible] is
always evolving
and traditions are always
evolving and melding
with one another, but
in another way you kind
of need some traditional
form and order for something
like this to be so
kind of so well.
So I'm wondering if you can talk
about the experimental
[inaudible] as a separate genre
versus kind of the slow
evolution of practices.
>> Gutsi Putu Sudarta:
The new creation
of [inaudible] in Bali today.
They say the basic, the roots
from the [inaudible] shadow
puppet performance like that.
And we bring [inaudible]
context with the new idea
and new element and new
[inaudible] also like that,
and we [inaudible] to
be the new [inaudible].
>> So every generation - because
every generation thought along
those lines or can you
define this as kind
of a new thing that's happening?
>> If I -
>> We can say that in the shadow
puppet tradition, they help also
like new creation in the
context of frame tradition,
but the other side if there
are new experimental creation
like that.
For example, when I
collaboration with my friend
in [inaudible] doing
the new performance,
[inaudible], this is very good.
The new element like the video
graphics like [inaudible]
and many things new [inaudible],
but I think the most important
is how I keep the [inaudible]
of my tradition and I bring
to the [inaudible] the most
important sense of tradition.
>> Andy McGraw: Yes we were
talking on the drive up here.
There's a major new
shadow puppet collection
from Germany that's just
been donated to Yale.
And a friend of ours is
up there and going through
and posting all these pictures.
And there was this picture of
how they put the box together,
and there was like
a spring in there.
It looked like it was
from the 30s or 40s,
and there was a spring in there
and I thought what is this?
How they were putting
it all together,
and he was explaining oh
the way we hid the box now
and the way we put
it all together,
that just emerged
four years ago.
And there are these new kind
of [inaudible] techniques.
And for me, I mean, this
is part of my experience
as an American everything
is tradition and ancient
and wonderful and beautiful,
and I'm constantly having this
like oh that's brand new.
That's okay.
And reminding myself
that's okay.
That's still totally valid.
I think part of the
difference here is
that new technology is
available, the projection,
and they're available
everywhere.
And at this point, they're
available everywhere more
or less at the same time.
So you get experiments in
California and Australia
and Bali with shadows and
projections and graphics
at almost the same time.
>> I think you also look
at it as a form of theater.
It's different than the form
of theater we're accustomed to.
Our theater is not [inaudible]
so why would you expect
theirs to [inaudible]?
>> Andy McGraw: Right.
Other questions?
>> I think the way I see it is
that in Bali the tradition is
so old and everybody,
all the Balinese,
the Hindu Balinese are
practicing it every hour
of the day.
So when they wake up, they
have all the tradition
to give to whoever it is.
They have what do you call them,
they have offering everywhere.
So the tradition is very strong.
And so that's why nobody - you
know, you have so many tourists
and whatever, but it's very
strong so nobody can touch it.
And when they dance
and [inaudible]
and everything it's all to God.
It's all for their God.
You know, it's not
for the people.
It's for God.
And so, everything is for God,
and it's very [inaudible].
And they practice every day,
every minute, every hour.
It's the practice is
very - I mean it's -
so nobody can touch it and
everybody leave them alone.
Is that correct?
Yes. But you go there, you see
all the offering everywhere,
and [inaudible].
You know like the one
[inaudible] the priest went
up to see what's going on.
>> Even though it's
about to explode.
Yes.
>> In spite of the technology
and everything, he wasn't afraid
to go up because he wanted
to do his own thing
according to his religion.
So that's how I see it.
I don't know whether
I'm correct or not.
>> What I'm always
fascinated with is this - yes,
there's a lot of [inaudible].
There's a lot of just
doing of the religions.
The making of the
offerings and the praying,
the temple ceremonies
it's every exhausting.
And yet, I'm always meeting
people that - a cab driver
on the way to the airport
after research this summer was
from this traditional
village where I was sitting,
but he was really getting
into this new Buddhist text
that was coming out of
being published in China.
It was kind of being introduced
into Indonesia, and he wanted
to ask me about had I ever been
to a charismatic Christian
service and what's that like?
I mean, my experience as
an American is you're kind
of totally assimilated
and there's not a lot
of critical thought
or you reject it all
and you're completely
idiosyncratic
and you don't even
have a [inaudible].
And to find people that are part
of very structured communities
and yet have a real critical eye
and they're saying it's almost
like they're in a buffet.
I'll take a little bit of
this and a little bit of that.
And maybe 10 years later, I'm
going to be a different person
and I would have
learned other things.
And I'll evolve as a spiritual
being even though I'm still
doing these things within
a particular community.
And for me as an American
that's so unique and different
and I kind of have this
hang up and jealousy.
>> If we had that
on a global level,
we would be in a
different state.
>> Yes. Any other questions?
Great. Let's give Pat Gutsi a -
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.